life in Victorian England was pretty
for most people let's imagine for a
moment we're walking together down the
streets of a British town in the early
part of the 19th century ahead we see a
figure begin to emerge from the haze is
it an alien is that an antenna in its
pocket or is it just pleased to see us
no it's a man and as he moves closer we
see he's carrying a long bamboo cane
that he uses to tap on the Upper Floor
window of each house that he passes
he's a knocker up also known as a
knocker upper someone hired to wake
people in the morning to ensure they get
to work on time starting in the
industrial era in the times before
reliable and cost-effective alarm clocks
knocker ups were the people who got you
out of bed in the morning which makes
sense it's no surprise they needed a
little extra motivation to get the day
started